We're going to begin today by,
uh,
going to the end of my previous lecture,
and taking up again the topic of he ness of being crossed eyed to,
um,
to give you my final thoughts on that.
Uh,
then we are going to us promised,
move to the character among the galley slaves that I call the prisoner of sex.
And,
uh,
finally move on to the Sierra Morina to the woods and to the complicated,
stories,
uh,
that,
take place.
Uh,
there
now we said that he neces cross eyedness if such a word exists is a monocular
and convergent monocular meaning of one eye.
One eye goes into,
uh,
the other.
So it,
this,
uh,
does not allow him to perceive reality clearly,
but slanted by the,
uh,
conflicting angles of his visual access.
It is,
it is a sword and this is the main point of what I'm trying to say is a sort of
innate or congenital internal perspectivism prior to any perspective is in based
on the multiple points of view provided by several characters.
Um,
perspective is in instead of Lantis,
which as I've mentioned before,
is the topic of Cervantes criticism presuppose the unified visions of several
characters who view or something like the like mum Breanna's helmet,
I.
E.
The barbers,
uh,
basing and disagree on what that happens to be.
Each sees reality in a way that represents his or her point of view and his or
her way of being,
but he ness has been crossed,
I'd suggest to me that such individual visions are already an obstruction.
And the hasty assumption,
the assumption that each one,
uh,
that each look is singular and represents only one individual,
but being cross eyed,
uh,
means that within each individual they are conflicting views and therefore
conflicting ways of seeing.
And this is very much in line with the way that Cervantes characters behave at
all to themselves often.
Now.
Uh,
so the global result is not a unified Barack conflicting vision,
uh,
within each of the character.
And I said that this,
uh,
kind of double vision is,
is it's called diplopia.
So awful sounding word of Greek origin.
I grew up,
yeah.
So,
uh,
the,
the new model I propose based on this observation that he does his cross eyed
and giving it the importance,
uh,
is that is a new model of conflicting,
of conflictive being a conflicting being within him or herself,
uh,
capable of seeing simultaneously,
in two ways.
Uh,
if there were already an internal dialogue of sorts within each of the,
of the characters,
this condition should Vantis,
uh,
represents as is usual with him.
Uh,
in a very funny way.
when he nest,
uh,
who was the first who jumped free.
Remember after they took away the chain,
he leaped free and does embarrassed.
And I'm quoting upon the plane and setting upon the fat,
the fallen commissary,
he took away his sword and his gun with which leveling it first at one,
then at another without discharging.
And he cleared the field of all the guard on quote being crossed eyed.
It's what I'm suggesting here.
Uh,
allows heinous to a guard,
each one of the guards at the same time or one after another with one eye is
looking at one with the other eyes,
looking at the other with a sword in one hand with a gun in the other.
And this is I think the way that said this is representing this double vision of
uh,
of heaviness.
Uh,
if you,
if you don't read those lines carefully,
you missed that subtle point that he needs to,
can do that because he is cross darling.
So with that,
having said that,
I move on to another prisoner who has,
uh,
been generally overlooked but uh,
and who occupies all of one paragraph.
It is the,
the,
the prisoner or the galleys slaves that I call the prisoner of sex.
Uh,
and it shows a Cervantes is remarkable ability to create a character with a few
brush strokes.
And I am going to read and guide you to page one 67 where the passage is
contained.
He has been asked us all the others why he is going to the galleys and he
replies,
I am going for making a little too free with two,
she cousins German of mine and with two other cousins,
German,
not mine.
This is of course 18th century English,
meaning that he was making it.
I said we're with two cousins of his and two of the girls who were cousins of
each other but not office.
I continue in short,
I carried the just so far with them,
with them all that the result of it was the increasing of kindred.
So intricately the no cashless can make it out.
The hole was proof upon me.
I had neither friends nor money.
My windpipe was in the utmost danger.
I was sentenced to the galleys for six years.
I submit,
I submit it is the punishment of my fault.
I am young.
I'm life may last and time brings everything about if your worships and your
cover letter has anything about you to relieve us actually in the original is to
relieve these poor wretches you takes distance from the others,
God will repay you in heaven.
And we will make it the business of our prayers to be,
seek him that your worships life and health may be as long and prosperous us,
your goodly presence deserves.
Okay.
So he,
he has,
he has been,
uh,
sentence to the goddess because he was having simultaneous affair with four
women,
two of whom were his cousins on to others who are not,
uh,
we're cousins to each other on how to progeny,
a series of children whose family ties were difficult to untangle.
They were cousins,
uh,
brothers and sisters and so forth and so on.
And as you can imagine,
okay,
now the historical reasons behind this on Cervantes is very careful in,
in,
in couching all of this,
uh,
stories in very precise historical reasons is that men were needed for the
galleys of the time,
uh,
because of Spain's,
overseas,
uh,
adventures.
Uh,
and so sentences,
uh,
where,
change to send more prisoners to the galleys.
And the age limit was Lord,
I think it was two 16 or something like that.
So,
uh,
these are,
this is the reason behind it.
Now he is brazen and to George by his being good in Latin.
Oh Gosh,
I forgot to read that.
And the other,
the,
at the,
at the end,
uh,
where he says the one of the guard says that he's a good Latina who do that he's
good in Latin and so forth
and wearing a robe.
It shows that he's a law student.
Uh,
and this is very,
uh,
significant.
There were many law students at the time,
uh,
and they were masters of rhetoric,
conceal logistic thinking and arguing of course.
This being the,
uh,
skills that a lawyer's presumably,
develop.
Uh,
the kind of syllogism that we,
we've got.
You're too young maybe to remember,
uh,
when,
when President Clinton was being quizzed about his relationship with Monica
Lewinsky and he,
uh,
answered one of the questions.
It depends what it is,
is,
uh,
being evasive.
He wanted to have everything defined he was just using.
So,
uh,
the other precise,
um,
uh,
legal background here is that he,
has engaged in what was called complex fornication.
There was simple uncomplex,
fornication,
simple fornication was a consensual sex between two individuals of different
sexes.
Um,
who our own married.
That is simple for niche,
uh,
complex fornication.
You can imagine one of the partners is married,
two of the,
uh,
of the partners are married to other people.
They are of the same sex and so forth and so on.
And of course,
the,
the sentences for complex fornication,
uh,
increased.
You see,
and,
uh,
here he has engaged in complex fornication because he has a committed incest,
having had sex with his cousins,
two of them for good measure.
So,
uh,
but
yeah,
he's a legal training is,
uh,
evident here in the,
he's trying to turn what is a criminal case,
insist to put it in modern terms into a civil case.
It's a question of inheritance law.
Oh,
how are we going to figure out the inheritance when these children,
when the children's family ties are so complicated.
So,
as you can see,
he has subtly in his discourse,
tried to uh,
diminish his culpability,
but of course he is a guilty Oh,
incest and therefore has been sent,
uh,
to the maximum sentence six years in the,
in,
in the galleys.
Um,
so he shuffles a question,
uh,
do a question of inheritance law and you will be hearing a lot about that today.
Uh,
what is the case of incest criminal case incense is to make love,
uh,
or to engage in sex with someone you cannot marry.
According to Canon law,
I don't know,
being religious law and according to cannon law,
uh,
there are all kinds of prohibitions.
But customers you are not supposed to marry,
although dispensations can be obtained from the church and all of that.
Of course,
you cannot marry your mother.
You're going to marry your sister and so forth.
But it goes down to your,
your,
uh,
for your customer.
You cannot marry or none.
All of that is under the prohibition of an instance.
But certainly here he,
uh,
has been guilty of,
of incest.
And this is why he is being sent to the goddess.
You also notice that he says,
well,
this is the proper punishment for my crime.
As if he knew him being already a budding lawyer and say,
I accept this.
And uh,
he says,
uh,
well,
life will go on.
I'm young.
I'd come back from the galleys and so forth,
which was very unlikely,
um,
uh,
that he come back,
alive and then he disappears.
But not before,
uh,
jumping on donkey haughty and taking the basic from his head and whacking him a
few times with it.
That's the last we hear of these.
A prisoner of sex who is a kind of libertine in the making and he and the
others,
uh,
disappear into the woods,
into the same woods where Marcella disappeared right away and into the same
woods into which Don Quixote and central are going to,
uh,
go,
also running away by,
uh,
from,
from the law.
So notice again what I said at the beginning.
House advantage has created this rather,
uh,
complex characters in just one paragraph.
And by just his speech,
what he says and how he says it.
So now we go into the Sierra Morina,
uh,
an inter,
what is really the core of part one of the cohort which is made up of all of
these,
uh,
stories,
that we will be hearing about in the next few classes and that you are reading
now.
Uh,
they're running away from the Holy Brotherhood about which I've spoken several
times before.
Uh,
because they are fugitives from justice and this is the overarching plot.
They are running away from justice in reality.
They're running away from justice.
That is in the real time of the period.
They are,
uh,
in fact that you will see later when they are captured,
being pursued by the holy brotherhood.
Uh,
they are uh,
uh,
they are criminals who in some way are uh,
expiating the sins in,
in,
in the woods.
The woods are kind of labyrinth or revision of hell.
A remind ful,
uh,
in some,
aspects of Dante's inferno,
some of its features such as the s parody of the landscape,
the cracks and so forth.
They are a far as possible from civilization.
It is a world of disorder and madness.
It is also the desk,
blah,
the unpopulated which,
uh,
in,
Spanish law meant,
uh,
areas,
not covered or protected by the law,
the desk Polo.
These are areas where the law and where the power of the state of the crown did
not reach their one.
This uses that,
uh,
those areas,
to send his characters into,
into,
into danger,
into confusion and into wireless.
Now
the Sierra Morina will be the setting over a series of tightly related episodes
all dealing with the question of love and more mundanely with the issue of
marriage.
Yeah.
Now the interpret stories that come after the Marcella and we saw stow episode,
which prefigured them and Rosina this disastrous frutation,
uh,
makeup as I said,
the core of the park,
one of the Quixote,
these stories peak and a resolve for the most part together with the main plot,
the plot involving Loki Hotel Sanko,
uh,
which I as I said,
resolves itself when he is captured and sent back home.
This is a set of narrative strands tightly woven around two of the principal
drives in the book.
One Donkey halters love quest for Dulcinea and the series of crimes and
misdemeanors perpetrated by the Algo and his squire that lead to his pursued an
apprehension.
The interpolated stories have in common with a central plot and with the
Marcella and we taught them interlude and with each other,
the perpetration of offenses do passion with the results with which result in
injuries to honor body on property and what the result in need for restitution
recompense requite all pardon or revenge
in all of the marriage neumes as the inevitable and most appropriate form of
reparation,
as well as the most effective kind of narrative closure.
Marriage is also in this context a form of punishment.
Now
these stories involve potentially only quote marriages and most of them contain
violence of some sort on equal in the sense that the individuals involved come
from different social classes and,
and that difference is what motivates some of the many of the conflicts,
but not all.
But although peanut law again looms over the episodes,
the peanut low applied to criminals like Don Quixote on Sancocho,
uh,
the most developed legal aspect in them in this store is derived from Testa
mentoree law,
uh,
sampling already an issue in the Marcella Crisostomo conflict.
You remember how much importance was given to the fact that they have both
inherited wealth and how they had inherited she being a woman,
he being a man and so forth,
inheritance and marriage codes,
both regulating succession,
drive and constrained the characters,
restitution and compensation cooperate to make whole what they damage in the
process of channeling their desires.
Do you remember you,
if you know something about law,
you know that to make you whole is to bring restitution,
uh,
to you for some damage,
or lost that you have incurred.
So the same,
uh,
symbolic topology,
a reappears that we have seen already between the,
the,
the road on the,
in now here it is between the woods and the in between the [inaudible] and the
wilderness,
which will be also a good way to translate this Pablo,
the wilderness
and the going back and forth from one to the other is punctuated often by
interruptions in the narratives interruptions that we will consider carefully
later today.
Marriage has to do with the law of course,
as well as with the closure of stories.
Uh,
thought it is an important structural issue to structural in terms of narrative
structure.
Marriage is the ending of many tales and place on the married and lived happily
ever after,
so to speak.
The end of many tales.
That's the how things are resolved.
Our order is restored,
uh,
and succession is insured.
The questions of love and marriage,
which,
which were important issues both from a,
uh,
social and literary point of view surface.
Here I in the episode of [inaudible] Marcella,
I underline through,
uh,
stories of young people,
the young people.
I have written their names here and I should get out of the way.
Uh,
so that we have them clear Scada,
Daniel,
Lucinda,
Fernando and Donald [inaudible].
I forget often to say don't Fernando,
but it say,
it says don't Fernando in the text because he is entitled to the Dome.
Um,
now these are decisive episodes in which advantage is dealing with love and
marriage and a significant point in western history,
both social,
it both in social and literary terms
is love and integral or even necessary part of marriage or his marriage.
Principally the social and economic contract.
Do young people have the right to choose whom they marry?
All of these questions have obvious answers today,
but not then.
And not for a long time.
Even narrow one into the 20th century.
In some societies,
marriages were arranged.
A,
I remember Gaietry Spievak,
uh,
well known critic a theoretician,
telling me she's from India,
that her mother had only heard her father's voice once in another room before
the day,
which she married him.
Uh,
the arrangements were being made and she heard the voice of this man who would
be her husband for the rest of her life.
Uh,
these are things that seem very,
very far from our,
uh,
lives,
today,
but not at the time.
The issue of marriage was being debated in the 16th century.
And he will continue to be debated through the centuries.
And it is an important topic in Cervantes because it has to do with social,
legal and also with,
with,
with the show of love
now significantly it is now that sanctuary learns to his astonishment,
do see Nass real identity.
Ah,
she is the daughter of a,
of of Lorenzo called Trello.
Of course he knows who this woman is.
Is that do Sudan?
Uh,
the story of donkey halters logo for her is the background for the stories of
Cardenio Lucinda Fernando under [inaudible] because Don Quixote's love of,
well,
don't sell Lorenzo could have,
could have led to an unequal marriage that of an Aristocrat,
even if a minor or is to grab with a country last,
uh,
which is,
on an equal marriage.
As I've,
as I've already said,
is one of the constants in all the stories in the Sierra Morina and reflect,
reflect the society in flux where there is these incipient class mobility.
The 16th century in Spain was called by a Medico Castro,
great historian and critic,
a conflictive age.
And part of the conflict was this social effervescence,
this social instability about which I'll speak more in the course and the course
of the semester,
I'll don't say appeals to Don Quixote or Alonzo Kiano because of her manly
qualities,
which he draws forms into sublime courtly love.
It was sublime.
Courtly love,
beauty.
Geez,
Mandy,
in the sense that we will learn,
she's brawny,
uh,
strong used to hard labor,
in,
in the fields.
I think that this is the fetishistic appeals.
She has four for them for,
uh,
for Loki Halter that,
as opposed to the women here in his class once suppose who are,
who are civilized,
done and,
uh,
and so forth.
I'll don't saw,
uh,
would be a more sexual I in a more physical,
an open way.
So,
uh,
this is what it is.
I think behind,
uh,
his infatuation with her.
Yeah.
What does Don Quixote's love of?
I'll don't sir,
tell us about love.
I don't start.
Don't see now this is one of those lessons for life.
I told you in the first lecture you might learn in reading the Quixote.
Quixote is also about live your lives.
What we learned from donkey Hotez passion for Odomzo,
whom he turns into those scenario is that when in love we invent the object of
our desire and that that object depends on the projection over our own inner
demons.
So this is something to learn for life.
I told you,
you,
uh,
quite a few things.
I'll be pointing out others,
but this is perhaps the most important and urgent for you to learn,
at least today.
Okay.
That'll settle the cast of,
of main characters in the stories in the Sierra Morina so that we can untangle
this as much as we can because it can get complicated.
And I'm going to also,
or unraveled is social economic background behind all of this.
Let us begin with Gardanio.
[inaudible] the name suggests a Garda.
They know it means purple.
Yeah.
Bright Purple,
bright purple with passion
in terms of literary history.
Cardinia is a minor Orlando Furioso.
The audio's those protagonists in the poem of that name who goes Berserk when he
suspects that are and Angelica has betrayed him with middle row,
uh,
you more.
This is that famous poem Orlando who you also that I have mentioned several
times and if,
or a literature major,
a literature person you should read at some point
got Lanio is mad.
As a result of the lovers threesome,
he roamed nearly naked and image of his savagery of his regression to the world
of,
of nature.
He's a wild man in the renaissance tradition.
The renaissance,
the figure of the wild man appears often.
Madness and love are embodied in Cardinia as they are in the math night in don
Quixote because Cardinia was also a double of Doki haughty.
And in fact,
uh,
Doki Hata has a feeling of the uncanny when he meets Gardenia for the first
time.
He says,
I'm boring.
Uh,
from page one 83,
don't be haughty.
Quote,
advanced to embrace him and held him in a good space,
very close between his arms as if he had been acquainted with him a long time.
How quote
perhaps he had been acquainted with God venue,
being acquainted with himself and this is what the line suggests.
So look,
Quixote discovers in Cardinia.
Okay.
Sort of a of double cause then you is a poet.
We discovered this because of the,
uh,
of the uh,
um,
little bag they find oh,
rotten in the,
in,
in the woods.
Don't get held down.
Santo a that contains a book of poems and texts by Gardenia.
He is,
uh,
he is,
we have again,
literary texts read in the novel as we did with green sauce,
almost song.
Remember that episode like Resource Tomo,
Daniel is the Petrarchan or [inaudible] poet,
sick with love,
but through Arca,
the great Italian poet about whom you have heard is the
one could see almost the creator of modern poetry,
14th century and Garcia Lasso,
whom I have mentioned before,
I think,
but ignored.
I mentioned them again.
A disciple of pay truck was the great Spanish Boyd,
the Great Spanish Board of the 16th century who brought about a whole revolution
impolitic language in the Spanish language 16th century cause last relief from
about 1501 to 1536 live very short life solo.
Quixote is very happy to have found this text and I'm very uh,
curious about who the author might be,
where our son Joe is very happy to have found a hundred gold coins.
And as you may have noticed,
sanctuary is not very interested in discovering who the owner of the bag is
because he doesn't want to have to return the uh,
uh,
the money
now
got a venue and Lucinda
okay.
Belonged to the low nobility.
They are either logos,
I don't Quixote with sufficient wealth to make their marriage a desirable.
Yeah,
both would gain,
she would gain social status because convenience status is higher and he would
gain wealth because she is rich.
Like Marcella Harris state would become kind of Daniel's dowery guarantee in
succession and reassuring,
reassuring prospect to her parents because she is a woman and there will be,
again,
that's indication of what I said.
There will be some concern about the legacy being lost.
We added capital.
Would him boot even improve the lineage?
Of course,
Doro payer
on the other hand
is a,
is a commoner.
She is the,
uh,
the rich farmers daughter and she far below don't Fernando's status on marrying
her would anger don't Fernando's father because she is his vassal.
Her name.
As you may have already noticed,
rhymes with Dorothy Neha,
you will see other instances where Cervantes uses a rhyme,
uh,
echoes of this nature to establish connections.
So running we don't see now there is something of a mirroring or echoing effect
here.
A version of what donkey halters and dosing.
There's romance could have been,
I told you,
same,
you know,
relationship except that the hold these hold the Duke that is Fernando's father
is so wealthy that while the increase of the state would be welcome,
it would be,
uh,
it will not be much of an incentive.
Now.
So much,
uh,
for Cardinia for now and Lucinda,
now I moved to Fernando or don't Fernando who is the most,
uh,
really complicated of these characters.
He's not exactly a hero.
No.
He is the character most vexed by judicial and economic pressures.
Uh,
who are the source of most of the troubles here having seduced or out there and
married Lucinda under false pretenses.
He is guilty of a stupor of rape
and the priest at some point clans to denounce him,
whereupon he will become a fugitive from justice like Don Quixote.
Fernando's actions have sent Gardenia under if they are into the wilderness and
left leucine that in a dangerous situation from which is she also wants to
escape.
Uh,
but she's abducted by Fernando in that story that is told sort of laterally.
And if you could,
this would have gone into this story.
We would have had an endless sequence of stories.
Uh,
uh,
so it's just left hanging.
What happens to her when she's,
uh,
abducted from accumbent and so forth and so on?
Uh,
don't Fernando is it on one type thinking of don't wound the seducer
first appeared in western literature in a play by till.
So the Molina Spanish play right of this 17th century,
uh,
who Fernando has caused injury to [inaudible] family.
It's not just to them individually,
to each one of the young people by compromising their honor and a state meaning
their social status and economic position.
There is an implicit costs and in policing it please,
it's subtle but strong cause,
uh,
for,
for Nando's,
criminal actions don't,
Fernando is an anxious,
say dumb.
I have the word here.
It comes from the word say wounded in Spanish,
which means second.
Okay.
Second Dome means a second born son.
Not to explain,
don't Fernando's socioeconomic status.
Ima expound a little bit on a Spanish institution,
the [inaudible],
which is that work out here,
even the Middle Ages,
Castilian law had elaborated the institution of the Majora go and entailed state
the mass of wealth and property whose integrity and continuity was guaranteed by
exceptional testament three laws and entail state,
uh,
in law is to limit the inheritance of property to a specific line or of EHRs in
such a way that it cannot be legally transferred.
I'm just giving you the definition from Webster's because not everybody knows
what it entail.
State is,
as the name implies,
Majora,
Asco,
he hold my daughter,
my daughter,
he ho,
my son,
my your eldest son.
Okay.
My ass go.
The,
my euro Roscoe consisted in the privileging of firstborn males in matters of
inheritance.
He,
the first born son inherited the title and the bulk of the endowment they might,
your ass go was an entire,
an entire mint entailment device to ensure the accumulation and retention of
wealth within one family by preventing it this personal through marriages.
Because if you had three songs and each inherited the same and each barrier,
different woman,
of course,
then that,
uh,
the state begins to be dispersed and diminished
by the middle of the 12th century.
The king allowed the establishment of my,
your ass goes that comprise the entire villages.
Am I your Asco could also be a royal grant from the king as reward for some
special deed in the theater.
[inaudible] this is a word or something.
You better learn as I told you,
they were going to learn some details or Spanish history and culture,
essentially seven books.
Uh,
she,
the party,
this is 13th.
Thank juries,
Legal Code that is a foundation of all Spanish law.
Uh,
the legal foundation.
[inaudible] Roscoe was ultimately grounded because how do you ground this?
And you know what,
why the first born
by making specific mention of God's command to Abraham to sacrifice Isaac,
his first and most beloved son.
So the ultimate authority was the Bible.
The Partido [inaudible] is also explicitly allowed the stater.
That is the one who,
uh,
whose legacy is being passed down to four bit.
His air from alienated the inheritance by sale or other means or obliging him to
pass it on to his own firstborn son.
And uh,
uh,
this legislation continued in the 16th century.
Commoners were allowed to,
uh,
to begin.
Uh,
my euro goes,
uh,
and uh,
and and,
and so forth.
Um,
so the proliferation of this man,
your ass goes generated a class of second donors or second born sons who are
left out of the patrimony.
See what I mean?
If only the firstborn could inherit.
And of course,
families had many sons and daughters and so forth.
There were a lot of second donors.
Hm.
They had the social status.
They're usually illustrious names conferred upon that,
but no financial substance or position in society and an uncertain future.
Eliot writes in Imperial's pain page one 14,
where I think you must have gotten already,
I hope
just under these two groups of magnets writes Elliott grandees and Tiepolos who
formed the elite of the Spanish aristocracy came a group which differed from
them in having no corporate entity entity of its own butch,
but which nonetheless enjoyed an acknowledged position in the social hierarchy.
This group consisted of the second donors,
the younger sons of the great houses,
this process,
no title of their own and we're generally victims of the mighty Roscoe system
which we serve the bulk of the family wealth do the elder brothers,
since they resources tended to be limited,
they were likely to develop themselves in particular to careers in the army or
the church or to serve the crown as diplomats and administrators on quote.
The term second dome by the way,
by virtue of its suffix is [inaudible] is the rogatory ground Doolan.
If you know Spanish is a Lumex alone,
someone who spoiled [inaudible],
a flirt and [inaudible] and nerd,
lazy bones and so forth.
Some of these are not very nice words for you to learn in this class
but it clearly points to the embarrassing position you see.
I'm trying to give you the background so you don't understand.
For Nando's situation
it clearly points would be embarrassing position of someone who can because of
his heritage act with self sufficient,
the self sufficiency of his class but has little substance to back it up.
The way out of the situation was contained in the refrain of the times.
IGLESIA martyr or Casa.
Yeah.
We will encounter it later,
uh,
in the cup too.
Stale when it is applied to the sons of a man.
Uh,
it meant that the second dong good go into the church,
um,
uh,
obtaining a position of some importance,
because of his family's connection,
Mara,
you could go out to see,
uh,
to seek,
adventures and to seek wealth,
go to the colonies and so forth.
Or Casa.
They attach himself to the court or to the court of a Grundy of someone who's is
employed.
Uh,
so cut off from their parents' legacy is the second donors became a social and
econ became social and economic climbers anxiously trying to make up for the
deficiency in status.
In this pain of the 16th and 17th centuries they make,
they became a class unto themselves,
a laborious one.
Once you say desperately seeking social and economic advancement,
don't Fernando situations and actions betray all the features of this class
though Fernando is dumb.
The second son of Duke,
Ricardo.
In fact,
the text reads in Spanish only Jose wounded and Duke,
the Duke or second son.
Um,
it only,
it meant all of the songs who were not the first born.
You don't.
And it wasn't only the second son,
but also the third,
the fourth,
the fifth.
They were all,
uh,
second donors.
Uh,
so the second dog is essentially he who is not first the only position with
entitlement.
One Cardinia appears in Fernando's home.
Remember,
he is someone by the Duke,
uh,
explicitly do with a companion with his older brother who is in line to be the
father successor.
And it's already a marquees.
Don't Fernando Ingratiate himself with a visitor,
a wins and wins him over to his side.
Gardenia was hacking rival or someone who reminds,
don't Fernando of the role that he would be called upon to play if he chose Gasa
rail to join,
uh,
the house over Grandy.
He could be a competitor in that by becoming the ally of his older brother,
he could come closer to wealth and power.
Don Don Fernando himself prevented as he is by law from acquiring them from his
father,
don't Fernando.
He's the odd man out.
Literally number three in this case,
uh,
which is worse than non second.
So he lowers Cardinia away and soon finds himself as his rival for Lucinda's
favors.
He said,
Doug [inaudible] could have an economic motive to when he said users out there,
even if he leaves her at first.
In fact,
when he does agree to marry her later,
uh,
dot.
Fernando is potentially founding a state that could have conceivably it could
become [inaudible] its own if it is rich enough and wealthy enough.
So,
uh,
restitution takes on a whole new meaning when viewed from this perspective.
So readers of Cervantes is time,
uh,
would have easily and immediately recognized all the testamentary conflicts
involved in different Anderson's actions and how the law impinges on his frantic
love life.
It is,
it's on Saturday.
That drives him to this frantic,
uh,
love life.
The economic,
social,
and ultimately judicial context.
That was the background of the Marcella [inaudible] episode is greatly expanded
then here to encompass deep social and economic issues.
In Castille during the 16th century.
The uh,
judicial situation is,
is accurate
and precise.
The source of the conflict in which Don Fernando,
Cardinia leucine down the road there and tangle is very precise.
The impending marriage of Leucine,
Don Cardinia is one that is again,
dictated by circumstances as well as by mutual attraction.
Gardenia.
Since that Lucinda is a maiden as,
uh,
as well as,
born,
uh,
not only well born,
but as rich as I am,
the description he gives of their youth and early love is like the implicit
blueprint of the marriage of Marcell and resource Tomo only that it was never,
uh,
it was nearer to taking place.
Actually,
their marriage was very near to dig in place when Fernando injuries.
But the ambition of social advancement first postponed the marriage because,
because Cardinia,
his father feels that he should go,
uh,
an answer.
Uh,
the Dukes,
someone's,
um,
and then leucine does.
Parents are,
uh,
I'm very interested in her marrying a know Fernando because it will be a leap in
social class.
So,
uh,
in fact,
Gardenia accusers,
Lucinda,
of,
of being,
uh,
of acting out of economic and social interest.
And this is the,
and this is why she,
uh,
she left him and this is the source of his feeling of betrayal that has sent him
into the woods.
Now we continue with the cast.
Doterra,
Doterra is the victim of a Nando's treachery,
but she's not a passive character.
I told you the run this is a women characters tend not to be passive.
And her actions are also dictated by the economic and legal determinations that
drive the others.
She's the daughter of commoners who are however old Christians,
and this is the,
the character's boast of this at a time when being suspected of having some
Jewish or Moorish blot background could be a disabling condition in the pain of
the time.
So they are a proud old Christians,
wealthy and so capable of social,
uh,
advancement.
Her father is cleaner,
low,
the rich say great name,
uh,
Glenara doe the rich and,
and he and [inaudible] mother have great ambitions for their daughter.
In fact,
uh,
when,
Dorothea makes up a story that we'll talk about soon when she's,
this has princess Mikami Kona,
uh,
she reveals that she is fearful of,
of,
of Fernando taking away,
uh,
her,
her wealth and ci,
if you remember her characterization in detail,
she's the one who ran the farm.
She says it.
She's the one who,
who did all,
all the administrative work in,
in,
in the form.
So while do not,
there is a woman and a vassal cheese when aware of her rights and legitimate
aspirations,
not to mention what an asset her own physical beauty can be.
We'll be talking about her physical beauty in the next class.
When Fernando sneaks into her chamber,
determined to possess her by any means,
she makes the decision to surrender,
motivated by love,
pragmatism and greed.
In telling her story to the priest,
the Barbara and Cardenio doterra repeats what she told herself at that crucial
point.
She says,
well,
I shall not this.
She's telling the story of what you thought at the moment of Fernando was
pressuring the issue.
When he snuck into the room,
she told her said,
well,
I shall not be the first who by the way of marriage,
has arisen from a low to a high condition,
nor will don't Fernando be the first whom beauty or rather blind affection has
induced to take a wife beneath his quality.
Since then,
I neither a make a new world nor a new costume.
Sure,
I may be allowed to accept this honor,
which fortune throws in my way.
Even though the inclination he shows for me should last no longer than the
accomplishment of his well for in short,
in the sight of God,
I shall be his wife besides to ride,
reject him with disdain.
I see him prepared to set aside all sense of duty and to have recourse to
violence.
And so I shall remain this honor and without excuse when I'm censored by those
who do not know how innocently I came into this straight for what reasons can be
sufficient to persuade my parents and others that this cavalier got into my
apartment without my consent.
So she,
uh,
she,
draws her balance and Ron and decides that the best thing is simply to consent.
Uh,
of course she has,
she has made him swear that they're going to marry a,
and he has,
uh,
he has,
she has made him swear in front of her maid who was the one who let him in that
he would marry.
And in this pain of the time,
I won't talk about this much more a secret marriages,
uh,
were allowed.
Meaning if you told,
uh,
your beloved in the darkness of night in a fit of passion that you wanted to
marry her.
And she said,
yes,
you were,
you were married because God is everywhere and God is listening.
So therefore,
presumably you are married.
Of course,
the temptation not to,
uh,
abide by,
by this,
uh,
marriage vows.
Oh,
what's great.
And the debates about it and the council of Trent as we will have reason to
discuss it in,
in classes,
uh,
concerning other marriage situations in part two.
We're great.
So don't,
is faith when the following both religious doctrine Castilian law,
which condoned premarital sexual relations relationships after [inaudible] such
as the one she has forced know Fernando to make,
he has to want to marry her not only before God will be for herself and her
servant when she plead her case at the end.
Doterra invokes this oath,
appears to don't Fernando's conscience and assures him that by law he's not
compromising his or his family status because nobility is transmitted by the
father,
not the mother,
not the mother's blood in Castiel as we had occasion to see in the case of
Greece and Marcella,
she convinces Don Fernando with the speech that that has this much verve as
Marcella's.
Uh,
and it's also couch in forensic rhetoric and terminology.
So this is what is behind,
uh,
this,
the,
the legal socio economic background of these,
uh,
of these stories about which we'll talk more,
but I'm now going to speak briefly and in conclusion about one important aspect
that I mentioned before under is interruptions.
Okay.
You will have noticed that all of these stories,
so the many of the stories are interrupted at some point.
The whole novel is interrupted in Chapter Eight when the narrator claims to have
run out of text.
So that is perhaps the most famous interruption in western literature.
But there have been many other interruptions.
The,
the,
the story Marcella and we source them or been told by Rivaldo and I'm bras,
you and others,
it's interrupted several times,
but the most and also that we have the,
the,
the proleptic interruption,
very funny interruption of central telling his story about the,
uh,
and her boyfriend and the goats starting to cross the river and all of that.
Remember that interruption.
But here we have,
uh,
other interruptions.
The most important and the most spectacular is that of Cardenio.
Cause Daniel says,
and I won't read you the text because you have it there and you must remember
it,
that he will tell the story,
but he will not be interrupted.
He does not want to be interrupted with questions or anything.
Uh,
so that,
that is the precondition for,
for his telling the story.
But of course,
at some point he mentioned [inaudible] and that,
uh,
is simply
too much for them,
Quixote to resist.
Uh,
and he breaks in and,
and,
and interrupts a gardenia and Cardinia goes berserk.
He Goes Berserk.
And he brings up this story about Queen Manasi Ma having been had an affair with
this lowly surgeon,
surgeons at the time did not have a very high status.
And of course our tax don't be on sanctuary and runs wild.
Um,
what,
what is behind all of these interruptions?
And there others,
what is behind all of these interruptions is that they allow
for a certain truth to come out because it's a rant disease showing that stories
have a sort of a,
of self generating a thrust,
uh,
that they follow a certain,
a script.
And that day they,
uh,
the veil,
the truth instead of telling it,
uh,
and that are less,
the teller is interrupted.
The truth does not come out.
So what is the truth here?
The truth here in the case of Cardenio is that he has this,
this paranoid fantasy that Fernando has already possessed Lucinda and that
therefore Lucinda is not fit for marriage with him.
It is unclear whether this happened,
but the story that Guy Daniel tells translate it into literature is that this
Queen Madonna Sema had this affair with the surgeon.
The idea of the surgeon of cutting a is obviously a story of the flowering that
is deep in his mind and that Lucinda has been deflowered by Fernando.
So,
so he has,
he has transformed the story in his fantasy,
uh,
into that,
do that,
a paranoid fantasy that what it reveals truly what is in his subconscious.
This is similar to what we had in the case of of donkey hot.
They're making up that Val Valerie romance that in telling the story in this
case,
interrupting the story in reveals another story.
What the Quixote as a book shows you chose those is how to read stories.
It is a primmer on how to read stories.
So this is the second lesson for life that you learn here
even,
or particularly if you're going to be a lawyer,
why lawyers do not allow witnesses to go on speaking for a long time.
They're taught to interrupt them because,
uh,
a witness can go on and lead the story,
get away,
and uh,
create,
uh,
facts that don't exist and so forth.
And the story that I always tell when I get to this point is one that happened
many years ago and that you are too young to remember,
but it's a story of Susan Smith.
You may not have heard of Susan Smith.
She lived in a,
in a town in South Carolina.
She had two children and she claimed that she had been stopped at,
at,
at a,
at a traffic light in her town.
Uh,
a black man had a gun into her car and,
uh,
um,
Bush they're out and run away with her children.
And she came on TV tearfully for almost a week.
There was a whole manhunt or over the United States to try to capture,
uh,
this,
abductor of the two children who of course,
uh,
claiming that he was black out it,
you know,
racist component to this whole thing until the certain Cherif
broke into her story and ask her questions.
And it turned out that Susan Smith had driven her car with her two children into
a lake,
gotten out and kill the children.
And this made the car disappear because she had a lover.
They certainly Fernando of the south of the South Carolina town who was wealthy
and a man about town debonair,
but didn't want to marry a woman who had two children.
Susan Smith was divorced.
So this came out when she was interrupted after she hadn't been on TV.
Tearfully telling the whole story.
So,
so if you interrupt a story being told the story,
gathering momentum from within itself,
you may get the real story to emerge.
And this is what happening in the interruption of all of these stories,
which happens over and again in the Quixote.
So what is most important to remember from this interrupted tails is to look for
the story not being told
or for the story being told.
Oh,
bleakly
as we did when considering donkey holders invention of the generic g Valerie
Romance,
which was a roundabout way of speaking about his own and societies and about his
lack of social status.
This is why in the psychoanalytic session,
the analyst will interrupt you and ask you questions.
Oh,
what did you say about mommy?
What did you say about Daddy?
Mm.
And doesn't let you go on.
It's in that give and take that the truth may emerge.
So this is what the store is the,
the,
the book is,
this book is,
uh,
is telling us,
we will see this narrative device up here again when Doterra,
this guys has princess me.
Kona makes up a story that is really that of her own turbulent love affair with
Fernando.
She cannot make up a fictional story without this emerging in the background.
And there,
there are little details that betray that does a story.
Uh,
so the Quixote is among many other things,
a book about how to read,
how to interpret the stories.
And in life we are surrounded by stories,
uh,
of all kinds,
not just in literature.